[Music]
we're not crying you're crying demi
lovato surprises a fan 13 years after
they first met as part of the
make-a-wish
how program you
oh it's so good to see you
it all started in 2009 when a little
lovatic named austin got the surprise of
her life amid her battle with kidney
disease i don't really know what i was
expecting because i was like my first
time meeting like anyone like celebrity
i think my wish made me a little bit
into the person i am today going to
shows and using music as that coping
mechanism and how
just strong and how much music can help
people in general fast forward to 2022
and austin is 23 and demi well they give
her another totally surprising and
totally heartwarming experience
[Music]
the pair reminisces about the first time
they met oh my gosh i remember your
little fig
and of course snapped a few pics
[Music]
austin is now thriving with hopes of
giving back as she studies to be a
speech pathologist and demi says meeting
fans like austin and seeing them soar
makes it all worth it over the years
working with make-a-wish i have seen how
a spark of hope can ignite a world of
possibilities for children with critical
illnesses
a child's fight against a critical
illness is not only physically
exhausting it can be emotionally
traumatic
granting wishes can often help kids find
light in the darkness of their
circumstances for demi not only are they
giving back to others they're also
giving us new music
[Music]
they recently posted to their instagram
story giving fans a little tease of
their new toons writing quote getting
emotional listening to my new album
because i'm so proud of it it's really
important to me to
embrace my my sound as as an artist and
also become more authentic to who i am
and get this demi says it's my absolute
best yet and so representative of me
where i started and who i am today i
want to release music that is different
that i've never done before we're going
to stay tuned for a release date
fingers crossed that it's sooner than
you think but until then no doubt demi's
new album will be out of this world wow
whoa
oh
did you just
yo yo hold the phone yeah it's a topic
they're exploring on their peacock
docu-series unidentified with demi
lovato i think it's important for me to
talk about my experience so that more
people don't feel alone in their
experiences do you feel like it's like
present in your everyday now are you
like constantly looking around and
feeling more
i definitely have it in the back of my
mind everywhere that i go no matter what
i'm doing it's
yeah it's in the back of my mind